[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuantos de los que estamos hoy acá se
dedica a lo que le gusta
cuantos de los que están hoy acá
descubrieron de pequeños qué es lo que
nos motiva qué es lo que nos entusiasma
cuantos de los que están hoy acá se
divertían en su proceso del aprendizaje
cuantos de todos los que estamos aquí
todavía
no sabemos qué es lo que me gusta
lo que no está entusiasma
qué es lo que nos motiva
pero si sabemos que dentro nuestro hay
algo en lo que somos realmente buenos
ustedes creen que todo este ciclo del
autoconocimiento que enlazaba las
distintas etapas de nuestra vida no está
relacionado con nuestra educación
hace un tiempo atrás llega a mi casa una
de mis hijas un día de clases normal en
la escuela de enseñanza tradicional abre
la puerta trae en sus manos un arbolito
de navidad y lo deposita sobre la mesa
estaba enojada y me dice mamá ese
arbolito no es mi arbolito
como hija que nuestra regalito
de ser bonito no es mi arbolito porque
hay dónde están las mariposas y ahí
donde están las flores
yo había pegado todas las lentejuelas de
colores
la seño me dijo que estaba mal
y lo tuve que desarmar
quien dice que algo está mal o que algo
está bien
porque no nos centramos en ese proceso
de lo logrado en todo el esfuerzo que me
conllevó realizarlo y que lo disfruté
capaz no salió como yo quería
pero lo logré lo hice lo realice
estas situaciones y otras situaciones en
estos 16 años en la que soy mamá de
hijos en edad escolar me fueron
descubriendo
esa sensación de esto no me cierra
he estado
hay algo que estoy buscando que no estoy
encontrando
hasta que en un momento después de todos
esos años llegue a un basta
un basta y necesito buscar alternativas
educativas distintas para mis hijos
si estamos dentro de una mochila de
educación
baldor vamos a ver que dentro de esa
mochila no hay bomba de borrar
como que no hay goma de borrar
si escucharon bien no hay goma de borrar
porque no hay goma de borrar porque en
la pedagogía baldor nos enseñan
que en la vida se actuó de mala manera
si me equivoco si quiero a alguien en
algún momento lo puedo borrar esto que
pasó consignadas
tengo que actuar reflexionar y
transformar eso entonces cuando vemos
cuadernos de la pedagogía baldor vamos a
ver que entre letras entre cuentas vamos
a descubrir flores y corazones que
transforman
mi hija no estaba solamente enojada por
el hecho de que le habían dicho que eso
estaba mal creo que lo que más sintió
ella fue ese dolor de destruir lo creado
no porque si esto que me gusta tanto y
lo dice de esta forma porque no puede
quedar así
a ver
qué es esto
una rama para un niño puede ser una
espada
o para un niño puede ser un bastón
para un niño puede ser un caballito
o una varita mágica
ahora
quién puede hacer esto
esto es esto
en valor se trabajan con elementos sin
terminar por ejemplo sus muñecos no
tienen rostro no tienen una emoción que
me viene del muñeco hacia mí sino yo
según mi estado anímico según el proceso
en el que estoy ese día
le pongo la impronta a ese muñeco en
valor se trabaja con materiales genuinos
con maderas con aromas con maderas con
con lana conversión con dos materiales
que me hacen recordar desde la aroma
desde las sensaciones
baldor todo a través de las vivencias
todos a través del juego todos a través
de eso que estoy creando imaginando en
el momento que estoy realizando una
cuenta un dibujo
todo es a través del movimiento y el
movimiento impulsado porque por el
entusiasmo pero el entusiasmo de quien
nace miren esta maestra
el entusiasmo nace desde la misma
maestra desde el momento que plantee esa
nueva pregunta frente ese nuevo desafío
en val d'or
el fin no es el resultado
el fin es el proceso
en val d'or
no importa como quedó el arbolito el
resultado sino el proceso todo lo que
disfrute todo lo que aprendí realizando
este arbolito
hace
un tiempo atrás lo digo con mucha mucha
alegría cada vez que salía de mi casa
una de mis hijas se escondía detrás de
mí cuando apareció una persona que era
desconocida que la veíamos muy poco
ella me abrazaba con sus brazos les
espiaba así desde atrás
pero siempre escondía detrás mío
en junio de este año nos invitan a una
fiesta que es muy característica en las
escuelas baldor que es la fiesta de los
farolitos nosotros como papás nuevos que
recién está vamos entrando en la
pedagogía de la escuelita de nuestro
pueblo morrison del interior de la
provincia de córdoba viajamos invitados
a esta escuela de las sierras de córdoba
cuando llegamos
nos encontramos con una escuela en la
montaña
abrimos la puerta del auto nos bajamos
lo primero que se siente es muchas risas
risas de niños y voces de niños
entusiasmados en ese momento se acerca
una mujer
que no conocíamos se presenta como la
maestra de la escuela de las sierras
se dirige a mis hijas por su nombre
y dijo una simple y sencilla pregunta
dijo que venir a jugar
en este momento
tomé conciencia
de tres cosas
una
que mi hija estaba a mi lado
que mi hija estaba mirando a los ojos a
ese adulto desconocido y le estaba
respondiendo
y tres
que mi hija estaba corriendo por la
montaña yendo a jugar con niños
desconocidos en un lugar desconocido
en ese momento
me di cuenta todo lo que ella había
ganado en ese medio año en la escuela de
pedagogía bárbaro
muchas
muchas veces la maestra de nuestra
escuela me invita a ir a la escuela
llegar a tver o venir la mañana
siempre uno está ocupado
un día no iba otro día no iba hasta que
después esta experiencia
y dije quiero ir a ver
desde el primer momento
descubrir un recibimiento
que antes lo había visto pero no lo
había observado
ese maestro recibiendo cada niño con ese
contacto con la mano
y esa mirada hacia el niño
pueden ser el lugar ese niño llegar a la
escuela es que tu maestro
en este de esta bienvenida y sentir ese
adulto ay acompañándote este adulto está
acompañándome
después los niños comenzaron a regar la
huerta barrer a hacer trabajos con
tierra pero nadie les dijo que tenían
que hacer eso y observaba que era por el
solo hecho de imitar a ese adulto
referente
comenzó la ronda con las rítmicas
siguieron los trabajos en el aula antes
un saludo inicial
flauta tejido cuadernos cuentas letras
desde el entusiasmo era todo un nuevo
desafío que lanzaban para esto para el
otro y entre todo eso lo que más me
llamó la atención que en la clase de
flauta
hubo más que de una ocasión
y ese niño que así en ese momento
ese niño buscaba con sus ojos a ese
maestro
y que encontraba en esa mirada
encontraba una mirada de mucho amor y
respeto
una mirada que decía acá estoy
acompañando te para que vos los hagas a
eso solo
porque vos podés hacerlo solo
yo creo que vos podés hacerlo solo
y ese niño agarraba esa flauta de nuevo
con ese ímpetu imitando al maestro
imitando al maestro
realmente cuántas veces
ha pasado que dejamos de intentar algo
por miedo que nos haga mal a que nos
salga mal o que la mirada de otro sea
que nos va a salir mal
cuántas veces nos pasa
estamos en estas situaciones en que
necesitamos
y esa otra mirada que nos apoyen
imaginen que eso venga desde la mano
desde nuestra infancia le damos una
pregunta varias
que somos
solo este cuerpo
somos solo esta mente
o también somos sentimientos o son mucho
más que eso qué pasaría si de niños
pudiéramos tener una educación integral
en que se nos cuiden todo lo que somos y
que además de eso esté ligado al respeto
por las etapas biológicas de nuestra de
nuestra vida que no se nos adelanten
procesos una educación en donde nos
ayuden y alimenten nuestra
auto-confianza
esa auto-confianza que yo descubrí de mi
hija viéndola correr por la montaña
como padre y val d'or
no es ir a dejar a tu hijo a la escuela
y olvídate
como padre es valor se es caminar al
lado de tu hijo
como padre y valor
descubrí que el compromiso es mucho más
grande del que creía cuando elegir
elegida pedagogía
esta escuelita en nuestro pueblo nació
por un grupo de padres que querían otra
alternativa pedagógica para nuestra
comunidad
del momento sumarme me di cuenta
el gran compromiso que significa educar
que no es algo externo que es algo que
no sería adentro para afuera y algo que
es que tiene que estar acompañado y de
la mano de los maestros
algo que se trabaja y se cultiva para
para hacerse adulto este adulto
referente digno de ser limitado
las maestras lo grafican de una forma
realmente muy sencilla ellas nos cuentan
que
la relación familia escuela maestros
padres es un signo infinito el niño sale
de la escuela de esta forma vuelve a la
familia de esta forma
qué pasa cuando vuelve a la escuela
paso en este momento
hay que trabajar
y hay que acompañar
de forma individual o de forma familiar
eso que hay que trabajar y acompañar les
quiero contar cómo se hace
saben como en val d'or nos enseñan
y nos hacen visualizar desde el primer
día esto imaginen un abrazo
un gran abrazo entre padres
un gran abrazo entre padres y maestros
respetuoso lleno de amor firme y en el
centro en el centro en el centro de los
niños
hace ya 16 años que tengo hijo en edad
escolar mis mamá de cuatro hijos los dos
más grandes ya están en edad
universitaria y secundaria
y en ese momento cuando estaba eligiendo
la educación de mis hijos mayores me
preguntaba cuáles escuela sería mejor
cual la escuela sería mejor eso me llevó
a la búsqueda de la respuesta entre
pruebas entre escuelas de mi pueblo
escuelas rurales pero la respuesta a la
llegada y por qué no llegaba la
respuesta por qué
con el tiempo descubrir
que la pregunta no era la correcta
con el tiempo salió en la luz
la respuesta
y la respuesta es que quiero una
educación para mis hijos en donde puedan
crecer libremente donde puedan
equivocarse donde puedan conectar con la
naturaleza
quiero una educación en donde ellos
puedan fluir en lo que le gusta en donde
puedan conectarse con ellos mismos
quiero una educación en donde nadie los
compare
en donde puedan de forma sana ir
conectando con su vocación
esta charla la titulé de esta forma
que se hagan la pregunta
qué pregunta
los invito a preguntarse qué educación
eligen
qué educación eligen para sus hijos
[Aplausos]
[Música]